The first assignment you can chose to do for this course is to talk about how
these semantic networks can be used to represent Raven's Progressive Matrices.
We saw a few different problems in the first lesson. So take a look at how
the semantic networks we've talked about today can be used to represent some of
those other problems, and write your own kind of representation scheme.
In addition to writing a representation scheme, also talk about how that
representation scheme actually enables problem solving. Remember what Ashok
mentioned about the different qualities of a good knowledge representation that
is complete. It captures information at the right level of abstraction, and
it enables problem solving. So write how your representation can enable problem
solving of two by one, two by two, and three by three problems. You don't need
to use the exact same representation scheme that we use, and in fact you can and
should use your own. Also remember that your representation should not capture
any details about what the actual answer to the problem is, but rather it
should only capture what's actually in the figures in the particular problem.